[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal sur
tv 78 bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
dans cette édition du jeudi 2 juillet
voici les titres de l'actualité locale
c'était l'un des tout premiers
événements sportifs depuis mars un
meeting d'athlétisme se déroulait hier à
versailles sur la piste du stade mont
boron 200 participants venus pour la
plupart des clubs des yvelines nous
étions sur place
la relance par l'économie verte une
solution avancée en tout cas après la
période de confinement un challenge
destiné aux pme et start-up a été lancée
pour favoriser les collaborations en ce
sens à l'origine le pôle mov'eo et
d'entreprises segula technologies de
trappes et puis c'est un monde qui
attend impatiemment une reprise totale
celui du spectacle à aubergenville le
cirque dans les étoiles se renouvelle
malgré l'annulation de sa tournée de
nombreux projets ont été imaginés 50
propositions pour une nouvelle
génération de la décentralisation elles
ont été remises aujourd'hui à emmanuel
macron par le président du sénat et
sénateur des yvelines gérard larcher
elles sont le fruit d'un groupe de
travail de parlementaires issus de tous
les groupes politiques du sénat
l objectif replacer les collectivités
territoriales au centre du pays les
propositions préconise plus de souplesse
d'autonomie et de pouvoirs pour les
régions départements et mer moins de
discours plus de proximité a même prôné
gérard larcher dans une conférence de
presse ce jeudi
écoutez à ce propos sophie primas
sénatrice des yvelines
nous allons présenter un plan de
décentralisation déconcentration de
l'état nous pensons vraiment que c'est
une des leçons de la crise du coc vide
mais c'est une des leçons sur laquelle
nous travaillons depuis longtemps depuis
la crise et gilet jaune semble que cette
notion de proximité cette notion de
capacité à répondre de façon plus proche
sur le terrain est plus agile et plus
réactive et plus facile est un des
éléments de la route de de la
restructuration de notre paysage
politique donc dès la semaine prochaine
dans les jours qui viennent gérard
larcher il fera une proposition
président de la république sur une
proposition de loi sur la
décentralisation et la déconcentration
d'état que je pense un élément majeur
pour la suite
rappelle emmanuel macron avait demandé
au président de l'assemblée nationale du
sénat et aussi à celui du conseil
économique social et environnemental de
lui remettre des propositions pour la
fin du quinquennat
c'était l'un des tout premiers rendez
vous sportifs en france après le
confinement le club d'athlétisme de
versailles organisé hier un grand
meeting au stade mob auront 200 athlètes
réunis les autorisations pour la tenue
de ce rendez vous ont même été obtenu à
la dernière minute ce le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros les organismes
ont souffert pour cette reprise mais les
sourires étaient sur toutes les lèvres
après plusieurs mois d'attentes l'union
athlétique de versailles a organisé ce
mercredi 1er juillet l'un des tout
premiers meetings d'athlétisme en france
post confinement au total 200 sportive
venu des yvelines et de la région
répondu présent aller retour à la piste
c'est énorme c'est cool premier sentier
de toute la saison
ça pique ça fait un peu mal au genou
mais le retour à la pisse énorme je
trouve ça fait du bien ça fait du bien
de reprendre les compétitions parce que
on avait repris les entraînement nez
l'esprit de compétition
ça me manquait un peu l'esprit de
compétition il ya du monde les puces et
on voit le résultat de les entraîner
l'entraînement l'eau rendez-vous a été
validé la toute dernière minute par les
instances l'autorisation finale a été
donné à 13 heures le jour même
les organisateurs ont dû répondre au
contexte sanitaire du moment fallait
respecter les gestes barrière avoir les
autorisations de la préfecture de la
ville de versailles de la direction
départementale de la cohésion sociale
donc ça a été un véritable parcours en a
limité le le meeting à 200 personnes
environ pour éviter qu'il y ait trop de
monde sur le stade et en respectant à
tout un parcours pour rentrer sur le
stade et sortir du stade le club
d'athlétisme espère maintenant pouvoir
organiser d'autres meetings d'ici la fin
de l'année 2020 une compétition de lance
est notamment à l'étude à elle les
organisateurs ont profité de ce rendez
vous mercredi soir pour rendre hommage à
jean marc fresnel l ancien adjoint aux
sports de la mairie de versailles est
décédé début mai des suites de lakovic
19 il avait 71 ans c'était un grand
passionné d'athlétisme président de la
course paris versailles
une minute de silence a été observée en
début de soirée au stade mont boron on
écoute le président de l'union
athlétique de versailles jean marc
trénel c'était l'adjoint aux sports de
la ville de versailles
il est un ancien athlète du club c'est
le président du pas de la grande
classique paris versailles
ces jeux lui qui a soutenu le club quand
le club avait des difficultés il ya une
douzaine d'années
voilà donc tout cela jean marc a été
emporté par l'aco vide
donc c'est avec un peu à un d'émotion
que son organisme était quotidien le
sport toujours avec ce match de football
caritatif organisé en septembre à la
celle-saint-cloud stars et anonymes se
retrouveront pour récolter des fonds en
faveur de l'association sos gazelle
l'interview de l'organisatrice de
l'événement par michael et demi d'euros
un rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas
match de football caritatif sang
organisée le 26 septembre prochain à la
celle saint cloud l'événement réunira
des stars et les fonds seront reversés
au profit des enfants de l'association
sos gazelle
pour nous parler de ce rendez vous avec
nous via écran interposé véronique
chaplin organisatrice de cet événement
bonjour bonjour alors pourquoi vous
organisez ce match à la celle saint
cloud véronique est bien dans la
continuité du type break et des
rassemblements sportifs de haut niveau
caritatif
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer le
président du csc loi qui lui même joueur
de foot et qui nous a proposé à
l'occasion d'une rencontre contre le
variété club d'intégrer des joueurs sos
gazelle souvent des anciens du psg mais
d'autres clubs
donc les joueurs du cs ces lois et les
joueurs dassault est gazelles pour jouer
contre le variété club et l'ensemble des
bénéfices de cette journée avec
également des enchères seront reversés
pour les enfants de sos cazelles d'où
vous est venue l'idée
véronique et bien en fait c'est en
discutant avec mickaël lui au président
du csc loi de dire que outre ss gazelle
organiser une à deux fois par an des
événements mais lorsqu'on peut être co
organisateur et qu'on a la chance de
rencontrer des gens qui également à vide
des stars pour lui c'était l'occasion de
nous rendre la pareille de nous soutenir
de nous aider et quand il m'a sollicité
m'a demandé est ce que vous voulez faire
partie du club de foot lui qui non
seulement
ouais on va intégrer le match de foot
mais on va aller plus loin on va faire
un peu comme le tiebreak une journée
enchères une journée festive
on va inviter également des
personnalités alors vous organisé depuis
près de 27 ans le tiebreak sur les golfs
des yvelines vous avez dû l'annuler
cette année à cause du coc vide 19
forcément évidemment compliqué pour vous
ça a été tiré parce que ça fait 28 ans
qu'on organise ce type break roland
garros qui est lié au tournoi de roland
garros pendant les qualifs et cette
année alors que tout était sous contrôle
que nous partenaires fidèles nos
sportifs no parano école était prêt et
surtout on avait choisi un sublime golfe
le golf par robert hersant il a fallu
tout annuler alors dans notre malheur on
a beaucoup de chance et nos partenaires
sont fidèles et en plus de ce match de
foot qui annule la veille de
roland-garros cette année roland garros
démarre le 27 septembre
on a décidé de maintenir le tibet sur le
magnifique golder sens avec l'ensemble
des partenaires ce sera mardi 1er
décembre
et même s'il fait un peu froid le thème
du père noël les enfants et c'est donc
la fête sera tout aussi belle quel est
le concept du tiebreak justement s'il ya
une partie de golf avec des stars mais
également les activités pour les enfants
je crois exactement l'idée c'est de lier
trois mondes le monde des enfants et des
jeunes le monde des entreprises beaucoup
de pme de chefs d'entreprise et le monde
des sportifs
donc il ya deux choses en parallèle il
ya une compétition amicale de golf avec
des pro de golf des joueurs de roland
garros des sportifs de haut niveau et de
chefs d'entreprises
et à côté de ça il ya des ateliers
multisports et des olympiades avec la
boxe le foot le rugby l'athlétisme à
chaque fois des champions qui en cas d
école des yvelines par rapport à ce
match de football est ce que les
sportifs ont répondu présent tout de
suite
les célébrités ont répondu présent tout
à fait j'étais très étonné parce que je
me suis dit qu septembre octobre à
l'aide des mois très chargé et quand on
a appelé nos amis ça soit patrick mboma
kambouaré alain roche amara simba
patrice loko philippe ndioro ils ont
tous dit oui spontanément et quand j'ai
appelé des défis légalement ce qui veut
dire qu'il ya un vrai attachement ssd
les gens se libère et ça ça fait plaisir
alors les fonds sont reversés aux
enfants des sceaux s gazelles est ce
qu'on peut nous en dire un peu plus
alors en fait on va faire à la fois une
tombola
il y aura une tombola avec des jeux à
gagner est donc là ça sera pour un 16
gazelle et on va faire ce qu'on fait
traditionnellement au tiebreak on est en
train de récolter des maillots de foot
collector des maillots de rugby des
raquettes de tennis et on va le signer
toussaint bien sûr et on va les vendre
aux enchères comme on fait d'habitude au
tiebreak voilà donc
s'il ya des gens passionnés par des
parts des objets collectors qui n'hésite
pas voilà est ce que tout le monde peut
suivre cette rencontre à ce que
quelqu'un d'extérieur peut venir voir ce
match tout à fait alors l'idée c'est
justement comme c'est au sein du csc loi
c'est d'inviter le plus grand nombre et
le public peut venir ils auront la
chance de en plus d'être avec ses stars
et puis de partager un moment sympa
parce qu'en fait les jeunes du csc loi
vont également jouer avec ses stars donc
ça va être une grande fête c'est festif
l'entrée sera gratuite et bien
évidemment tous les gens désirent line
et même les amis des yvelinois peuvent
venir au csc loi à 15h le samedi 26
septembre pour s'amuser puis pour
soutenir la cause aussi est-ce qu'il ya
intérêt sportif ou c'est plutôt une
ambiance bon enfant
alors c'est avant tout une ambiance
bonne enfant si le plaisir pour les
stars de se retrouver pour les
partenaires de voir si les champions
pour les stars de faire une belle oeuvre
pour les enfants parce que sayid y
tiennent ils veulent toujours rendre ce
qu'ils ont reçus mais derrière moi je
pense que peut-être un peu de repérage
de futurs champions en vue je pense
qu'il ya des footballeurs qui sont
reconvertis là dedans et qui auront un
oeil a droit on peut être repéré nos
futurs champions de demain
mais est ce que les stars comme patrick
mboma voudront perdre sur cette
rencontre
ce qu'ils pourront perdre patrick mboma
ne voudra pas perdre quand on est
champion reste champion que ce soit
légal ou variétés ou les
les footballeurs de sos gazelle ils sont
très potes en dehors du terrain mais
l'idée que le le lancement du match et
démarrer ils vont jouer à fond pour être
fasse attention de pas se blesser quand
même parce que il reste des champions
ils ont cet esprit de la gagne de la
discipline et de l'effort jazeera
également le tiebreak le 2 décembre je
le précise dans un golf un exactement
elysées en parallèle c'est la même chose
il joue au golf pour s'amuser mais à
partir du moment où je vous la compet
avec le titre de champion je peux vous
dire qu'ils lâchent rien merci à vous
véronique chapin d'être intervenu dans
cette émission je rappelle la date de ce
match caritatif ce sera le 26 septembre
à la
celle saint cloud un mode économie avec
vous le savez une crise sanitaire qui
s'est muée peu à peu en crise économique
même si le redémarrage est désormais
enclenché une question se pose la
relance ne pourrait-elle pas venir de
l'économie verte c'est en tout cas la
conviction des mitec est basée à
montigny le bretonneux cette société
spécialisée dans les essais pour la
certification notamment dans
l'aéronautique et l'automobile a été
frappé de plein fouet par la crise elle
a repris son activité au travers de
tests autour des batteries équipant les
véhicules propres
le reportage de nicolas d'ombré et si la
relance de l'activité économique passée
par l'innovation technologique dans
l'économie verte
c'est une part de la stratégie choisie
par le groupe emi tech spécialisée dans
les tests de qualification et
d'homologation
elle a relancé son activité notamment
sur des batteries destinées à des
véhicules électriques
là dessus sur tout ce qui est véhicules
légers hybrides ou tout électriques bon
on a un très très bon marché très fort
et on développe actuellement je pense
des nouvelles méthodes d'essai pour que
demain on puisse mieux tester tous les
véhicules journal décidé de lancer des
bandes test de moteurs électriques et
cela testé et dans des cages de faraday
pour mesurer les perturbations
éventuellement émises par ces moteurs et
aussi d'un dé chambre anéchoïque
acoustique voir ou écouter plutôt si les
moteurs de pompe la peau bruit avec ces
méthodes de tests innovantes emitech
devrait recevoir une troisième batterie
en septembre à partir du mois d'octobre
des tests seront lancés sur des piles à
combustible à hydrogène
le véhicule vers un moyen pour ce groupe
de 500 salariés de relancer son activité
sous traitant de grands groupes la crise
sanitaire a eu des conséquences
importantes sur cette société bad
donneurs d'ordre donc pas de chiffre
d'affaires ou très très peu sur des
affaires qu'on avait commencé donc en
avril mais on tournait 40% du chiffre
d'affaires tant dans l'automobile que
dans l'aéronautique a rien eu du tout
moi soyons clairs donc pendant
pendant dix semaines et aujourd'hui
l'air nautique c'est le calme plat mais
l'automobile commence à frémir grâce au
tir et aux véhicules verts pour cette
entreprise implantée à montigny le
bretonneux les deux tiers de l'activité
sont réalisés dans l'aéronautique et
l'automobile
ils représentent plus de 60% des
missions de l'entreprise en 2019
un challenge destinés aux start up et
pme il est lancé par le groupe segula
technologies spécialisée dans
l'ingénierie ce groupe est basé à
trappes c'est en collaboration avec
movéo un pôle qui est rassemble
plusieurs acteurs dans les domaines de
l'automobile et de la mobilité
l objectif est d'accompagner la relance
de ce secteur en favorisant les
technologies vertes
question posée par nicolas landry
[Musique]
cette crise sanitaire arrive pendant une
crise un petit peu plus diffuse un petit
peu plus un petit peu plus profonde je
dirai qui et qui est la crise de de
mutation de l'industrie automobile on
voit bien qu'il ya une transition vers
l'électro mobilité d'une part et dans le
même temps on a bien sûr la révolution
numérique qui ce qui se dresse là dessus
les technologies numériques qui va être
très fortement le véhicule de demain
on peut penser bien sûr aux véhicules
connectés ou 4g et 5g ou au véhicule
autonome aujourd'hui vous avez des vous
avez vous avez un petit peu de temps
libre
parce qu'il ya moins d'activités
pourquoi ne pas faire un focus sur les
appels à projets qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui ouverts pour prévoir un peu
le développement de technologies de
demain
[Musique]
séduit la plusieurs domaines de
prédilection est plus un secteur mais le
premier comme vous le savez c'est
l'automobile on a été impacté par le
ralentissement des activités de no2 du
groupe clients français que sont psa et
renault
ces villas innove en permanence et
j'allais dire peut-être encore plus
maintenant
en fait c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
un levier pour prendre des rester
compétitif quand le marché va repartir
[Musique]
de chalon d'innovation sont des sondés
excellent moyen pour les grands comptes
de source et d'acquérir rapidement des
compétences pour pouvoir sortir
rapidement des produits compétitifs
il était question voilà de laisser aux
participants jusqu'au 10 septembre pour
déposer leur dossier de candidature
puis les dossiers seront examinés du
parti séculaire d'autre part pas mauvais
au cours des années et les finalistes
seront invités à peach et le 8 octobre
au présentiel de tous les experts de
deux cellules en
[Musique]
il se trouve qu'au niveau du département
de recherche et innovation de ces deux
là en travaille depuis longtemps sur des
innovations alors soit sur des énergies
des énergies propres soit sur des
projets de mobilité plus durable
on a lancé chez segula en fin d'année
dernière
un dispositif qui s'intitule explora h
le xp l'eau est rare qu'on présente
comme un hub de start up avec segula
clint challenge moveo on est vraiment à
la recherche de jeunes entreprises que
nos compétences pourrait leur permettre
d'accélérer et de gagner en performance
et peut-être en time to market ou si la
mobilité les transports l'énergie et
nouveaux matériaux ce sont les trois
grands domaines les champs d'exploration
de ceux de ce challenge culture le monde
du spectacle souffre particulièrement de
cette période de crise sanitaire et
malgré une tournée annulée le cirque
dans les étoiles ne s'arrête pas pour
autant de nombreux projets voient le
jour en ce moment et on en parle avec
marylène yapi chinois sous le grand
chapiteau du cirque dans les étoiles à
aubergenville les trapèzes et autres
monocycle sont orphelins de leurs
artistes
on est les plus touchées du confinement
puisque dont tout s'est arrêté pendant
le confinement est là bas tous les
rassemblements sont interdits les
festivals sont annulés donc nous voilà
toutes nos activités qui sont annulés au
moins jusqu'à la fin de l'été
du point de vue du spectacle alors pour
faire vivre ce spectacle malgré tout
véronique est mis en scène l'un des
personnages sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est que les gens nous répondaient les
gens parlaient aux personnages des
personnes âgées isolées biais qu'elle
était complètement coupé du monde et que
chaque matin elle était contente d'avoir
d'avoir ce petit post avec de l'humour
et du coup ça nous a donné
voilà le la pêche pour essayer d'avancer
[Musique]
monsieur pied a tellement séduit que la
compagnie s'est vu proposé d'en faire un
recueil à l'aide d'une association
locale travaillons avec les personnes en
situation de handicap
petite histoire du confinement peut être
commandé sur internet auprès du cirque
dans les étoiles
de son côté bruno est fait vivre saab
est imaginaire j'ai un petit peu mon
animal à moi c'est un animal imaginaire
et j'ai aimé composer tout voilà toutes
sortes de saynètes toutes sortes de
d'attraction autour de sa grande épopée
pourra être découverte par le public
prochainement en attendant que le
spectacle histoire de cirque puisse
reprendre sa tournée
[Musique]
à choisel le château de breteuil fait
durer le plaisir pour ce premier
week-end de juillet le site propose aux
visiteurs de faire un saut dans le temps
un spectacle en nocturne où les
visiteurs deviennent les invités du
marquée de la marquise de breteuil les
jardins seront aussi accessibles tout au
long de la soirée pour s'y balader ou
pour y pique les propos
recueillis par mélanie poker les
conditions sanitaires ont été
effectivement que dans contre les grands
rassemblements mettant pas possible la
journée de reconstitution historique
bretagne 1900 quand on devait faire la
quatrième édition au mois de mai a dû
être annulée alors l'équipe du château
et rester mobilisés et ils avons
réfléchi à un concept en soirée mais
surtout un concept de parc ouvre avec
des petits groupes d'une dizaine de
personnes qui vont partir toutes les dix
minutes pendant quatre heures
attention les réservations sont
obligatoires une deuxième soirée
proposée le samedi 11 juillet prochain
avant de vous laisser c'est aujourd'hui
la journée mondiale des ovnis les objets
volants non identifiés sachez que les
yvelines sont un département le
phénomène est bien présent depuis 1974
sur 205 apparition d'ovni signalés en
france 50 l'ont été sur le territoire et
des témoignages alimenté notamment par
l'apparition de crop circle dans des
champs comme ici à ce marché
l'oeuvre finalement deux professeurs de
sciences pour une leçon de géométrie
grandeur nature 13% tout de même de ces
signalements effectués reste aujourd'hui
inexpliquée
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]